the world faces two very big challenges
in 2009 one is a world economy which is
slowing down and in many places going
into quite strong of your session we
have to work on the recovery and that
means big spending and big church starts
learning quite a few countries in the
world in order to get it back going
again and many of us think that it's
going to be 2010 before some of the rich
countries really starts to move and grow
pot positively once more including I
think in a lupe and they're not the USA
that's one of our big challenges second
is that we have to come to an agreement
as a world on climate change and a whole
global d is setting out what all going
to do on climate change by december two
thousand and nine percent of this year
in Copenhagen and those are the two big
challenges are no two big challenges in
my view a linked and a difficult time
and people need to be get need to get
back to work it's a time when we can
think about how to do things differently
how to do them in a much green away and
many the green things actually on if
jobs quickly and a more labor intensive
and energy efficiency variance later
houses those are clear examples of that
so we have an opportunity as we push for
our green veggie push for a recovery to
make that recovery green and at the same
time the lay the foundations for a very
strong agreement in copenhagen on how to
cut greenhouse emissions at the end of
this year so let's take those two prices
the economic crisis and the fantasy
prices and put them together it'd be
great to hear what you think about how
we can handle those two the crises and
these are the subjects in Davos World
Economic Forum where I am now and
they're going to be the subjects when
the g20 against together that's the
Presidents and Prime Minister's of the
most important countries in the world
the 20 biggest as it were countries in
the world in terms of economics they're
getting together in April first and
second in London
and this is the time when we need to
grapple a those decisions and your views
on how we tackle the economic crisis in
the climate crisis at the same time
would be extremely valuable